♪ ♪ ♪
- Lift-off! We have a lift-off!
- That's one small step for man.
- Le 21 juillet 1969,
l'astronaute Neil Armstrong
est le premier êininininin
à poser le pied sur la Lune.
- That's one small step for man.
- Le 21 juillet 1969,
l'astronaute Neil Armstrong
est le premier être humain
à poser le pied sur la Lune.
- We choose to go to the Moon...
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour le président John
Kennedy, il était important
de battre lemememememe spatial
soviétique en pleine guerre
froide.
Le succès d'Apollo 11 a été
suivi de cinq autres missions
lunair c c c c certaines
ont séjourné jusqu'à trois jours
sur la surface de la Lune.
C'était il y a 50 ans.
Dans la mythologie grecque,
le dieu Apollon est associé
au Soleil. Artémis est s
et on l'associe à la Lune.
Avec Apollo, on a marché
sur la Lune; avec Artemis,
on va s'installer sur la Lune
en 2025, en trois étapes.
Plus tard cette année,
avec Artemis 1, le lanceur SLS,
Space Launch System, le plus
puissant de l'histoire,
décollera de Cap Canaveral et
emportera le vaisseau spatial
Orion, pour le tester, sans
équipage, à plus de 450 000 km
de la Terre pour une mission
de s s s s s s six semaines
avec orbite autour de la Lune.
C'est avec Artemis 2 et 3 que
commencera la participation du
Canada, parce que ces missions
enverront des astronautes
vers et sur la Lune,
et l'un d'eux sera Canadien.
ISABELLE TREMBLAY,
Agence spatiale canadienne
- On a quatre astronautes actifs
en ce moment à l'Agence spatiale
canadienne : David Saint-
Jacques, Jeremy Hansen,
Jennifer Sidey, Joshua Kutryk.
Ils sont tous qualifiés pour
des missions spatiales à venir.
- Le choix du Canadien
et des autres astronautes,aiaia,
est attendu l'an prochain.
- Les astronautes irontn n n n é
pendant les missions en Apollo.
Alors, ce sera la première fois
que des humains iront autour
de la Lune, derrière la Lune,la.
Et puis, ils vont donc vérifier
le fonctionnement de tous
les systèmes qui vont permettre
aux astronautes, par la suite,
de retourner sur la Lune.
Pour les 10 à 20 prochaines
années, on prévoit des vols
assez réguliers, à peu près
une fois par année vers la Lune;
des missions de plus courte
durée, au départ, puis des
missions de plus longue durée.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Puis, les astronautescocococon
spatiale en orbite autour
de la Lune, appelée Gateway,
"la passerelle".
DANIEL REY, gestion. systèmes
Agence spatiale canadienne
- Ça va être un laboratoire
d'expériences scientifiques,
développeme,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,
poste de contrôle, aussi,
pour les expériences
et les déploiements sur la Lune,
et c'est aussi une grande
collaboration internat
Le Canada se joint
aux Américains, aux Européens
et aux Japonais pour faire
partie de cette aventure.
- Le Canada construit un nouveau
bras pour le Gateway :le bras c,
deux fois plus petit que
les deux premiers, entièrement
robotisé, autonome.
- Canadarm 2 était assemblé
par les astronautes et entretenu
par les astronautes, tandis
que Canadarm 3 va pouvoirsesese,
complètement, prendre
tous les morceaux du système,le.
- Gateway sera la base de départ
pour des séjours de plus en plus
longs sur la Lune, où sera
inst
permanente, où il faudra
pouvoir se déplacer.
- Ce prototype-là a été utilisé
pour vérifier, entre autres,
les algorithmes de navigation
autonomes, pour vérifier
les concepts d'opérations
quand on contrôle à distance.
- Et pour se déplacer, il faudra
avoir des véhicules planétaires,
les fameux rovers.
ERICK DUPUIS, explo. spatiale
Agence spatiale canadienne
- On parle d'une mission
vers les pôles. Donc, ce qui
nous intéresse dans ce cas-là,c,
donc l'eau qui est prise
sous forme de glace dans le sol,
l'oxygène, l'hydrogène...
On veut aller analyser ça
pour bien comprendre la géologie
lunaire, évidemment, et aussi
pouvoir comprendre, si un jour,
on veut faire de l'extraction
sur place, mettons, pour appuyer
nos missions...
- Un défi technologique;
deux compagnies canadiennes
travaillent sur des prototypes.
- Ça prend 28 jours terrestres
pour faire une j
14 jours de noirceur,
donc ça devient...
- Le froid extrême.
- ... extrêmement froid,
exactement. Et puis, il faut
réussir à survivre à ça,
dans le eleleleleleleleleleleler
à mort. Donc il faut,
le lendemain matin, réussirveve.
- Artemis, vaste projet
international en parte
avec l'industrie privée,
veut explorer la Lune
et l'habiter pour l'exploiter.
- Le prochain volet,
c'est le volet commercial,
c'est-à-dire que là, on y va
d'une manière durable,
avec des partenaires, é é é é é,
il y aura une économie lunaire
et des activités commerciales
aussi autour de la Lune.
- Mais ensuite? La station
lunaire n'est qu'une étape
dans l'exploration de l'espace.
Artemis vise plus loin :
la planète Mars, plus facile
à atteindre de la Lune
que de la Terre.
- On va pouvoir expérimenter
des scénarios de missions
qui vont nous permettre aussi
d'envisager des voyages
vers Mars. La Lune, c'est aussi
un tremplin pour aller plus loin
dans le système solaire